Land und Brecht
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich
einmal bewerten Ort
ist mittlerweile eines der populärsten
Wörter überhaupt also meiner
unmittelbaren Umgebung ja nicht Leute
treffen natürlich in so vielen Jahren
ist weil wir nennen das ja hier zu Hause
gar nicht die Kinder hatte sondern das
ponyzimmer weil als wir hier einzogen
hatte meine Lebensgefährtin fand sie
diese Amazon Werbung so schön mit diesem
kleinen Mini Shetty also ihren kleinen
shetlandponie das von den großen Pferden
gedisst wird auf der Weide und dann
kommt Amazon und liefert eine Klappe und
durch die kleine Klappe kann das Pony
dann auch nach ihnen gehen
eine ponyklappe genau und da dieses
Zimmer so klein ist wie ein ganz kleiner
Ponystall und weil wir darin das
kleinstmögliche Schlafsofa hatten das
ist überhaupt gibt das selber außer wie
so ein kleines zotteliges Pony Größe
heißt das bei uns das Pony Zimmer
ehrlich
ich habe heute ein Thema für dich dass
wir eigentlich immer wieder Streifen
geht bei uns ja häufig um Moral oder das
was man dann auch Moralismus nennt diese
diese überzogenen Moralvorstellungen mit
denen wir
gelegentlich zu tun haben auch wir beide
und ich würde mit dir mal gerne darüber
reden was heute eigentlich Sünde ist
oder ein Vergehen oder Fehlverhalten und
das früher mal eine Sünde und
Fehlverhalten war und man kann das sehr
gut Aufhängen an den sieben Todsünden
sagen dir die sieben Todsünden was ja
klar ne das ist ja im Grunde eine wie
soll man sagen eine eine
Betriebsanleitung für den Menschen aus
der Sicht der Kirche kann man das so
sagen ja genau also es geht darum welche
Haltungen einnehmen soll dann gibt ja
auch die Zehn Gebote da ist geregelt was
man nicht tun soll aber das ist diese
anderen Gänge die sind in den zehn
Geboten nicht drin die sollte man auch
nicht tun aber die soll nicht der
Gesetzgeber im vorschreiben sondern die
soll der innere Gesetzgeber einem
vorschreiben genau also das soll man
sozusagen aus freien Stücken nicht tun
ja ich finde ja die Zehn Gebote sind ja
eigentlich sozusagen Regeln für ein
Zusammenleben in der Gemeinschaft und
ich finde die sollten uns auch noch mal
vornehmen die Zehn Gebote ja während die
totsünden ja eigentlich das Verhalten
des Einzelnen Regeln sollen ne genau und
das soll er aber selber reden also das
andere regelt ja die Gemeinschaft also
wenn es heißt du sollst nicht töten und
du tötest jemand dann wirst du
verurteilt ne aber wenn es heißt du
sollst nicht neidisch sein und du bist
neidisch dann ist das ein Problem das
musst du mit dir selber aushandeln
richtig es geht also sozusagen um den
inneren Gerichtshof in dir selbst der
aber von außen von der Kirche Fragen
auferlegt wird und damit kontrollierst
du letzten Endes den Menschen ich muss
also die sieben Todsünden vielleicht
müssen wir sie einmal kurz mal benennen
ja Hochmut Habgier Wollust
Zorn Völlerei sehr interessant night und
Trägheit und was mir auffällt wenn man
da mal so draufsteht es gibt ja
eigentlich noch eine Kategorie die fehlt
nämlich Verrat finde ich der Verrat
fehlt was interessant ist weil es
wahrscheinlich ein Hinweis darauf ist
dass Verrat eigentlich nichts ist was
uns Menschen so wirklich eigen ist wir
werden ihn versuchen geführt Leute zu
verraten oder dafür bezahlt eine andere
Erklärung sag mal muss ich ja überlegen
wo die herkommen ne also die diese
Auflistung der der Todsünden stammt ja
nicht aus der Bibel wie so viele ist
genau die heiligen drei Könige kommen
auch nicht aus der Bibel und die Toten
kommen auch nicht aus der Bibel sondern
es war ja so ich meine nach dem Paulus
das Christentum gegründet hatte muss ja
sagen paulus war das nur jesus wollte
den jüdischen Glauben reformieren
Paulus ist eigentlich alles
genau der hat intellektueller was Jesus
ja im klassischen Sinne nicht war der
aus dem Christentum eine Religion
geschmiedet hat so und das ist natürlich
wahnsinnig aufwendig sowas zu machen du
musst ja lauter Regeln und Bestimmungen
machen zudem Jesus nichts gesagt hat
oder du musst aus bestimmten Sätzen von
Jesus was ableiten das ganze muss ja
auch funktionieren du musst enter
einführen wie Bischöfe und Priester und
da muss es wieder Regeln für geben wer
darf das werden und wer nicht und müssen
die Leute jetzt Steuern an die Kirche
zahlen oder müssen sie das nicht also
diese ganzen Regeln die sind ja alle
dann nach und nach entstanden und es kam
ja mit neuen Situationen noch immer
wieder neue Probleme hinzu und das ist
der ganz großen Konflikte im vierten
fünften Jahrhundert waren die Frage was
ist eigentlich wahrhaft praktiziertes
Christentum denn inzwischen war das
Christentum durch Kaiser Konstantin zur
Staatsreligion in Rom geworden eine
Staatsreligion ist was ganz anderes als
das was Jesus im Sinn gehabt hat und
schon gar nicht hat er die Römer gedacht
das heißt das Christentum hatte sich
massiv verändert und es gab starke
Strömung in der Kirche die gesagt haben
ja aber das ist ja nicht Christentum
Christentum bedeutet wie Jesus zu leben
und das war die frühe Mensch Bewegung
der sie die die ersten Mönche das waren
diejenigen die Jesus nachfolgen wollten
die wollten eigentlich gar nichts mit
der Amtskirche die damals gerade in
schirmt und die dann zusammengeschmiedet
worden ist durch vor allen Dingen durch
Augustinus das war der zweite große
Kirchen die ohne Augustinus keine
christliche Kirche also erst Paulus und
dann 400 Jahre später Augustinus oder
350 Jahre später und die wollten damit
nicht so viel zu tun haben sondern die
sagten wie Jesus leben heißt Jesus leben
rausgehen in die Wüste ein enthaltsames
Leben zu führen ein Leben was nur Gott
gewidmet ist und das ist natürlich
ausgesprochen schwer und da entsteht in
diesem Kontext entsteht dieses Konzept
der sieben Todsünden also die Dinge die
einen am meisten dabei bedrohen genau
ein Leben wie Jesus zu führen
also die die Jesus hat diese Laster
nicht gehabt ne jesus war nicht neidisch
und Jesus weil ich habegierig der hatte
überhaupt keine materiellen Bedürfnisse
und der war auch nicht träge sondern ist
immer durch die Lande gezogen und hat
Jünger um sich geschafft oder sich darum
bemüht und er hatte keine Gier auf
irgendwas sondern war ganz bescheiden
und demütig und so weiter und dafür
wurden diese Todsünden damals initiiert
und damit hat hier die Kirche zur
nächsten Problem den die Kirche war ja
durchaus gierig und macht Lust und alles
was dazu gehört um als Institution
überhaupt zu funktionieren dann musste
sie ja ganz pragmatische Realpolitik
machen und denen sind diese Mönche unter
anderem die sogenannten Säulen heiligen
tierisch auf den Sack gegangen ja die
haben die als große Bedrohung empfunden
dass die die Kirche aushöhlen indem sie
wieder zurückführen zu dem was Jesus mal
gesagt hat die Säulen heiligen das waren
eben auch manche die in der Wüste waren
und auch tatsächlich auf Säulen wohnten
noch hoch also drei Meter fünf Meter
hohe Säulen da gibt's zum Teil heute
noch so in Syrien und in Ägypten Jan
Äthiopien triffst du zum Beispiel auch
Mönche wenn nur was du meine Äthiopien
das ist ein unglaublich schönes Land und
da gibt's einen Ordner meines lalibella
da war ich mal da hast du Kirchen die
innen sozusagen den den Boden
reingehauen sind ja also du du du gräbst
sozusagen den Text den Boden ab den Berg
ab in unvorstellbare Arbeit wie die das
gemacht haben müssen wir absolutes
Rätsel und übrig bleibt sozusagen eine
Kirche in Form eines Kreuzes die aber im
Boden versenkt ist das heißt um in diese
Kirche reinzukommen musst du erstmal
viele viele Stufen nach unten und hast
dann diese Kirche in Form eines Kreuzes
die fantastisch aus und der Hintergrund
war man wollte sich schützen man wollte
nicht dass diese Kirchen von weit her
sichtbar sind und dann gräbt man sie
sozusagen in den Boden ein und und dort
werden Messen gefeiert bis heute bitte
bitte das jemals gesehen hast das ist
echt der christliche klasse
gesetzlichen Kirche
deren Kirchturm ja nicht hoch genug sein
konnte richtig die sich ja übertrumpft
haben mit Kuppeln und Kirchtürmen und so
weiter um gerade weithin sichtbar
wichtig genau also mit deinem Bild von
der eingegrabenen Kirche bringst du das
perfekt auf den Punkt ja das sind
diejenigen die sagen Christentum das ist
das was ich mit möglichst reinem Geist
und reiner Seele mit mir selbst ausmache
und die anderen sagen Christentum das
ist hat ein Missionsauftrag und
Christentum das muss herrschen und Gott
muss auch die ganze Welt verbreitet
werden und und und ja das ist der
ursprungskonflikt wo in dem die
Todsünden entstanden richtig und du hast
dort eben auch das ist sehr interessant
wenn du wenn du dann da runter steigst
du hast ja ein tiefen tiefen Graben ja
und dann kannst du diese Kirche rein in
deiner lebst du dort diese Messe gesagt
für jemanden wie mich der an ganz
anderen Hintergrund hat etwas was ich
mir nicht vorstellen konnte David
gesungen da wird mit Weihrauch geschenkt
du bist am Ende vollkommen high wenn du
aus dieser Kirche rauskommst das war ein
großartiges Erlebnis empfehle ich ist
wirklich sehr wenn man irgendwie mal die
Chance hat nach lalibella zu kommen und
dort dann zum Gottesdienst teilzunehmen
lebst du Christentum noch mal ganz
anders und vor allen Dingen mit also hat
er für dich so auch so eine
karnevalistische Dimension was die gute
Laune angeht ja aber tief spirituell
tief religiös bedeutet den Leuten viel
und hat mich sehr sehr berührt und
rundherum sozusagen auf der
gegenüberliegenden Seite ja dieses
tiefen Grabens hast du Löcher in den
Felswänden drin und da drin wohnen bis
heute ihre mieten da wohne da wohnen in
München in diesen Löchern drin die
kriegen dann essen
hoch gesalzt sozusagen und und wohnen da
drin und der Teilen Radschläge kluge
Weisheiten ja Menschen kommen mit allen
Problemen dahin das familiäre Themen
oder andere Dinge sind und die beraten
Sie so ein bisschen ersetzen im Grunde
eigentlich ja Psychologen ne wir wir
gehen zum Psychiater oder zur
Psychotherapeuten genau und die geben
halt einfach mit diesem religiösen
Hintergrund Ratschläge für ein besseres
Leben und Leben dort wirklich wie
Eremiten also mit mehr ganz wenig Essen
sind alle wahnsinnig dünn und alle
wahnsinnig entspannt und sind dort sehr
sehr schöne Bilder gemacht hat mich
damals unglaublich fasziniert ja da
haben wir jetzt eine wichtige Grundlage
für die Diskussion weil wenn du da so in
der Höhle in Äthiopien lebst ne oder auf
so einer Säule in der syrischen Wüste
auf wen willst du oder neidisch sein
wenn du schaffst ja eine Umgebung in dem
Neid gar keine Rolle spielen kann oder
auf was sollst du gierig sein also wenn
du einmal diesen Abschied genommen hast
und einfach raus aus der Verlosung bist
ja nach weltlichen Gütern und Ämtern und
Fronten und so weiter zu streben dann
ist es ja auch nicht mehr so schwer auf
dir zu verzichten Hochmut was denn also
du sollst dich für den Größten halten
wenn du ein jeden Tag so alleine mit dir
bist du Vergleich für den größer wenn du
die ständig mit anderen vergleichen
und Trägheit mehr gut ich meine so ein
wahnsinnig aktives Leben in dem Sinne
machst du nicht aber an den Mönch also
diesen Mönch etwas anders ist das dann
im Hochmittelalter wird auch nicht der
Anspruch gestellt dass er die ganze Zeit
arbeitet sondern ist ja ein asketische
Uhu und der asketisch für Gurus gibt es
gar keine Arbeit und für jemanden für
den es keine Arbeit gibt gibt es auch
die Gefahr der Trägheit nicht es gibt
auch die Gefahr der Völler reinigt ne da
dreht sich ja auch um Essen ja also
jemand wenn überhaupt was hast und die
Regel ist in normalerweise du isst
möglicherweise vor Sonnenaufgang nach
Sonnenuntergang aber dazwischen nichts
deswegen sind diese Menschen auch alle
wahnsinnig dünn und und zum Teil so
erschöpft auch von dieser von diesem
ewigen Essensentzug dass ich ich
erinnere mich ich habe einen Gespräch
mit einem geführt auch in Äthiopien
anderer Mönch auf dem tarnersee du
mussten wir alle zehn Minuten das
Interview abbrechen weil er nicht mehr
konnte der einfach kaputt das hat den
vollkommen überfordert viel zu viel
Energieaufwand auf diese Fragen dieses
neugierigen deutschen Reporters zu
antworten dass das war der nicht gewohnt
alle zehn Minuten Pause und dann ging es
wieder weiter der musste sich erst mal
erholen das hat mich damals sehr
beeindruckt das war ein junger Mann kann
aus einer äthiopischen Beamtenfamilie
und hat sich vollkommen gelöst von
seiner Familie und auch von der Welt in
gewisser Weise und er sagte damals zu
mir ich bin ich bin tot für die Welt und
die Welt ist tot für mich das fand ich
irgendwie oh ja irgendwie gruselig und
gleichzeitig packt es sich ne wenn
jemand bereit ist so radikal mit allem
zu brechen was in irgendeiner Form so
das alte Leben war
das man stellt sich doch immer die
gleiche Frage ist das eine arme Sau oder
ist er im Haus überlegen ja
irgendwo mein Gefühl war zwischen diesen
beiden Polen flirten doch den Gedanken
richtig seit hin und her oder ohne
festen Boden ja das ist aber genau auch
der Gedanke der mir kommt wenn du über
diese Todsünden sprichst ne ähm ich
meine eigentlich kann man es begreifen
als eine Anleitung fürs Leben und
eigentlich sind das uralte Regeln ja die
ein bisschen ins sechste siebte
Jahrhundert und so weiter zurückgehen
was hat uns das heute noch zu sagen aber
wenn du dann mal drauf schaust merkst
ach du gute Güte
drin
ist natürlich auch wenn du als Säulen
heiliger oder als höhlenmönch lebst komm
selten schöne Frauen vorbei
ich hatte ja beim letzten Mal Ulrich
Roski das gerne wieder da heißt es in
lonesome Rider mit dem Fahrrad durch die
Wüste selten Kino niemals Frauen 40
Meilen in der Stunde oh wie Highways up
and down so und ich denke das gilt hier
auch selten Kino niemals Frauen ja ist
natürlich auch ein gutes Mittel gegen
Verlust er ist richtig ja aber die Frage
ist natürlich und das ist weil du gerade
sagst da flirten sozusagen die Gedanken
hin und her die Frage ist natürlich
richard ist das erstens erstrebenswert
und der zweite Punkt wer hat eigentlich
ein Interesse daran dass wir uns so
verhalten ja selten Kino selten Frauen
wem nützt das eigentlich coolibo ja
wieder das einer sagt so und da würde
ich dann immer sagen hast du dann
plötzlich die andere Seite ja also genau
also die Wüste zu übertragen auf eine
moderne Großstadt in 21 Jahrhundert geht
nicht im Maßstab 1:1 richtig selten Kino
selten Frauen läuft da schon mal niemals
Frauen ja genau
und die und die die Frage ist natürlich
und und da hatte ich auch immer als als
junger Mensch schon irgendwie ein Thema
diese unglaubliche Fixierung zum
Beispiel auf Sexualität die Sexualmoral
und das hast du ja in allen Religionen
eigentlich und irgendwann wurde mir klar
natürlich wer die Sexualität eines
Menschen kontrolliert der kontrolliert
den ganzen Menschen das ist ein
wahnsinniger Hebel um sozusagen
Einfluss und Macht über diesen Menschen
zu gewinnen ja und das war natürlich
auch der Grund und auch alle anderen
Bereiche ja also was hast du du hast
essen ja Völlerei du kontrollierst die
Sexualität
Neid Missgunst all diese ganzen Dinge
die hier Trägheit und so weiter du
kontrollierst praktisch den gesamten
Menschen wenn du diese Verhaltensweisen
so definierst und sagst okay da seid Ihr
aber nicht in Ordnung das ist eben gar
nicht typisch christlich ne da haben wir
in allen anderen Religionen eben auch
und da auch schon die die griechischen
Philosophen die so aufgeklärten
religionsfreien griechischen Philosophen
wie Platon haben sich darüber ziemliche
Gedanken gemacht also unter dem gleichen
Gesichtspunkt weil da wo der
wohnungsgefrönt wird
da entstehen auch viele andere
Bedürfnisse also jemand der sich
sinnlich richtig austobt der hat dann
vielleicht auch das Bedürfnis nach
vielen anderen schönen Dingen erleben
und Platan sei immer eine große
Konkurrenz zwischen dem privaten
Haushalten wo die Männer bei ihren
Frauen waren und wo er immer davon
ausgehen dass letztlich die Frauen das
Sagen haben und nicht die Männer und im
öffentlichen Raum ja wo also die die
Macht der Polis der Stadt und die
Politik stattfinden sollte und alles was
was Platon sich überlegt hat anstatt da
ging es immer um die Macht der privaten
Haushalte die zu brechen also die unter
staatliche Kontrolle zu stellen damit
man sich da nicht auslebt weil da wo man
sich auslebt da entstehen alle möglichen
wilden Bedürfnisse die der Staat nicht
mehr eingefangen genau und das ist in in
der griechischen Sprache der Konflikt
zwischen der Stadt ja wo die allgemeinen
Angelegenheiten geregelt werden und dem
äußeros ist das griechische Wort für
Haushalt und das können wir heute in
Ökonomie
ja das ist unser die die haushaltslehre
der Wirtschaft und Ökologie das überall
steht das Wort oikos drin und die ganze
Idee dass man sagte jetzt halte ich mal
ein bisschen da zurück und hob dich da
nicht so aus und und nimm deine Frau mal
nicht so wichtig und so weiter da ging
es immer darum dass man dachte dann
kriegen wir die öffentlichen
Angelegenheiten nicht mehr geregelt
genau das gleiche findest du in der
Kirche auch diese Frauenfeindlichkeit
der christlichen Kirche ja Paulus das
Viper in der Kirche zu schweigen und so
ist ganz klar in dieser platonischen
Tradition und das sitzt unheimlich tief
in uns drin ne
auch so die Idee sozusagen was alles
Sünde ist also Sünden Vorstellungen hast
du ja praktisch in allen Religionen ne
und was er interessant ist in dem
Zusammenhang auch Menschen ohne Religion
oder ohne
größeren Bezug zur Religion haben auch
eine klare moralische Vorstellung davon
was gut und was böse ist ja das heißt
offensichtlich ist da etwas was wir auch
brauchen was uns wichtig ist was uns ein
inneres Bedürfnis ist das finde ich
total interessant es gibt gar keine
Gesellschaft die nicht eine Vorstellung
von Gut und Böse haben es gab natürlich
sehr pervertierte Vorstellungen die das
was sie für gut gehalten hat wo wir
sagen würden um Gottes Willen denken wir
ans Dritte Reich richtig ja aber auch im
Dritten Reich war es eine Gesellschaft
mit Vorstellungen von Gut und Böse es
gibt gar keine menschlichen
Gesellschaften in denen es keine
Vorstellung von Gut und Böse gibt es
gibt auch keine Menschen in denen es das
nicht gibt außer Sie haben einen totalen
Schaden
aber es interessant nein im Grunde ist
eigentlich diese diese Lehre der sieben
Tod sind ist eigentlich auch wenn du so
willst an Herrschaftsinstrument gewesen
ne ja ein disziplinar Instrument
natürlich
treiben ja aber da würde ich sagen das
gibt es heute auch aber auf eine andere
Art und Weise nämlich
wir sind heute eingeflochten in ein
System von Normen von das tut man und
das tut man nicht das sagt man und das
sagt man lieber nicht so benimmt man
sich und so benimmt man sich besser
nicht
und dieses normgespinst das ist bei uns
ein ganz feinmaschiges Netz und wird im
Augenblick auch immer feinmaschiger also
die Chance irgendwas zu sagen was man
nicht sagen sollte oder was zu tun was
man nicht tun darf oder nicht mehr tun
darf das nimmt immer stärker zu
und deswegen kommt es eigentlich gar
nicht mehr so sehr auf dieses
Zwiegespräch mit dir selbst an wie beim
Mönch der dir sagt das versuche ich
jetzt mal zu unterdrücken sondern wir
wissen es ist opportun bestimmte
Verhaltensweisen mal besser nicht zu
machen wegen der Konsequenzen die einen
daraus erfolgen bei den unserer
aufregungsgesellschaft und in einer
Gesellschaft die dem Moralismus frönt
also ein unmoralischen Umgang mit Moral
muss man ja sagen ist eben sehr
gefährlich ist von bestimmten
Verhaltensweisen abzuweichen
insofern haben wir das anders geregelt
wir haben gar nicht mehr so viele
Gewissenskonflikte sondern wir müssen in
ganz feines Gespür dafür entwickeln wie
man sich zu benehmen hat und wie besser
nicht aber lasst uns doch mal die die
Sünden mal durchgehen fangen wir mal mit
Neid an und ich würde als erstes mal
immer die Frage stellen
wenn die dir so nach Schulnoten dich
selbst einschätzen soll ja also 66 heißt
weil sie sich auch negative Dinge
handelt trifft voll zu ja nicht durch
und durch und einfach habe ich nichts
mit zu tun mit night was würdest du dir
für eine Schulnote geben wobei Neid
würde ich jetzt tatsächlich sagen würde
ich mir eine weiß ich nicht finde zwei
oder drei geben ich bin kein neidischer
Mensch ja ich hatte aber immer und bei
dir würdest du mich kriegen
genau deswegen aber Neid nee Neid ist
etwas was mir sehr fremd ist ich bin
nicht neidisch auf Menschen ja also bei
mir ist es immer weniger geworden aber
aus einem ganz pragmatischen Grund nicht
weil ich mich so wahnsinnig geläutet
hätte wo bist du denn ja ich würde mir
das auch geben ich würde mir sogar eine
zwei geben also ich würde mich da
relativ positiv bewerten aber heute
früher war das mal ganz anders und der
Grund ist dass mir heute nicht mehr so
viele Leute einfallen auf die ich
neidisch sein könnte
es gab aber Lebenssituationen in denen
ich war von denen ich ja schon häufiger
berichtet habe so nach meiner Promotion
und vollständig arbeitslos und keine
Perspektive und das Gefühl zu haben
möglicherweise über Talente zur
Verfügung aber über keine die die
Gesellschaft irgendwie braucht oder
bezahlt und dann so neben mir zu sehen
ja wie die Leute ihren Weg machen und
wie das alles funktioniert und deren
mildes Lächeln abzubekommen als nur
sozusagen als gestrauchelter
Geisteswissenschaftler daneben steht in
solchen Situationen hat man dann ganz
anderes Gefühl ich hatte in einer
unserer allerersten weil
es auf Roger Willemsen gewesen bin
genau dass man Ranger und jemand der so
neidisch war ja der der weiß dass der
Neid schon in ihm wohnt
aber dass er heute nicht mehr so viele
Gelegenheiten hat sich auszutoben das
interessanten alte ist dieses also das
sitzt immer noch in dir das Roger Trauma
na ja ich denke jetzt heute nicht mehr
viel darüber nach nein also das ist
tatsächlich nicht mal unter uns
ich habe ihn ja später später ernsthaft
kennengelernt ne und wir haben uns sehr
gemocht und sehr geschätzt und das war
immer sehr vergnüglich und sehr teuer
also ich habe eine sehr sehr gute
Meinung über ihn aber eben aus dieser
Perspektive von damals Neid ist ja immer
eine Frage des Standpunktes auf dem man
steht und je nachdem wo der ist und wie
der ist ist man unterschiedlich neidisch
und es ist wirklich eine Frage der
Umstände also Menschen die in Siedlungen
leben in den alle anderen Häuser größer
sind als Iris ja da ist so der der
Neidfaktor natürlich irgendwie besonders
groß ne oder dieser ich erinnere mich an
dieses aufrüsten Mittelklasse Autos in
dieser Siedlung in der ich groß geworden
bin
also ich bin als wir ich gerade elf
geworden sind sind wir in so eine
Siedlung
mittelschichtsiedlung Mitte 70er Jahre
klassische graue mittelschichtsiedlung
gezogen und da fand ja dann diese in den
70er Jahre war ja auch noch Zeit für so
fallingen zweite Hälfte Anfang 80er
Jahre dann ist das richtig ab Helmut
Kohl Zeit da hat Deutschland ihren
großen materiellen Sprung gemacht und
das war dann an den Autos sichtbar und
man konnte also wirklich sehen damals
waren so diese diese klassischen
Statussymbole waren Opel Ascona und Ford
Taunus das waren die häufig
verkauftesten deutschen Autos ja also
keine Kleinwagen mehr sondern
Mittelklassewagen und wenn der eine
hatte dann rüstete der andere da dagegen
auf also innerhalb von drei vier Jahren
haben sich die ganzen Autos ausgetauscht
in der Siedlung mit Ausnahme von uns
natürlich ja wir hatten diesen alten
klapprigen VW Bus sondern ausrangiertes
Polizeifahrzeug ja dann hat sich auch
nichts geändert ja wir hatten oben noch
so Kabel für eine Blaulicht Antenne
kinderreiche Familie ja und die waren
dann umlackiert worden diese VW-Busse
die waren ja ursprünglichen Grünen und
weiß für die Polizei gewesen und die
sind dann so in so einem Senf Ton also
sehr hässlichen Ocker unseren Autor
haben wir gefahren bis es endgültig Müll
war super ehrlich aber so viel zum Thema
Neid also
gedeiht in Biotopen ja wo der Pilz der
daneben aus der Erde schießt ein
bisschen größer wird als man selber ist
ja das ist natürlich wir haben sehr
einsam gewohnt vielleicht lag da dass
ich nicht so viele Leute Reflex
entwickeln konnte wobei wenn du so
definierst und ich denke jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich zurück hatte ich das natürlich
auch logischerweise das doch klar und es
gibt ja auch die These das Leute sagen
Neid nackt und zerstört war auf der
einen Seite aber ohne Neid wäre die Welt
nicht nur
ärmer und langweiliger ohne Leid würde
diese Welt wie wir sie kennen überhaupt
nicht funktionieren naja so zumindestens
Kapitalismus funktioniert nicht
also wirklich und Bedürftige befriedigt
sind ja dann entsteht über die
Bedürfnisse hinaus bedarf richtig ja und
der Bedarf richtet sich natürlich extrem
nachdem aus was andere haben ja was ich
also glaube was ich so zu meinem Glück
auch noch brauche ob das dann früher
meinen Kühlschrank war oder ein
kachelbad oder eine Kies Auffahrt oder
oder Weißwandreifen und was ist nicht
alles an Status Symbolen früher gegeben
hat und heute gibt es das halt eben
immer noch muss ein SUV fahren und
vieles andere mehr also diese ganze
statuswelt würde ohne einen gewissen
Neidfaktor nicht funktioniert ja also
wenn wir mal ehrlich sind müssen wir
eigentlich jetzt gedanklich irgendwie
von zwei schon mal mindestens auf drei
oder vier oder fünf erhöhen sichert mal
ganz ehrlich sind
ja night night vielleicht nicht so von
uns definiert ja weil man neidisch ist
ja konnotiert auch mit missgünstig und
so weiter ja man könnte dem anderen das
schwarze unter dem Nagel nicht und so
weiter das würde ich für mich
tatsächlich
ausschließen dass ich gönne jedem alles
der Punkt ist aber ich möchte auch ein
bisschen was vom Kuchen abhaben das war
natürlich immer ein ganz wichtiger
Antrieb und ich glaube ja definiere mir
das über Gier definieren das über Neid
aber da spielt Neid mit Sicherheit auch
eine Rolle und dazu passt ja auch Neid
ist ja sozusagen du du es muss
vergleichbar sein innerhalb deines
Biotops wie du gerade sagtest was
interessant ist aus der
reichtumsforschung wenn du mit Leuten
wie Thomas droyen der gerade wieder ein
tolles Buch gemacht hat liebe Grüße
sprichst den kennst du mit Sicherheit
auch der sagt ja Leute jenseits der
Milliarde die haben kein Problem mit
Neid ja im Kanal hat Diskussion die sind
untereinander ein bisschen neidisch also
Jeff Jesus vielleicht auf max sackerberg
das mag sein dass man dann andere Themen
und wenn du siehst dass man ihn und
Maske und Max hackerberg sich
gegenseitig Prügel an drohen dann merkst
auch wie kindisch die zum Teil sind
diese Leute ja aber nein vielleicht
nicht im materiellen Sinn aber nein was
Einfluss anbelangt ja ich weiß was Image
in der Gesellschaft als wäre es das
größte innovationsgenie und so weiter
wer ist der der größte Hengst im Stall
des Silicon Valley und so ich glaube da
gibt es diesen nightfaktor nach wie vor
aber ich würde den Neidfaktor gerne mal
in moralisieren und mal gucken was ist
denn das für Mechanismus in uns wenn ich
das jetzt mal mit ganz trockenen Worten
bezeichnen dann ist das ein angeborener
Sinn für Unfairness die einem wieder
fährt
night entsteht nämlich nur in
Gesellschaft und die eine
vergleichsweise hohe fairnesskultur
haben
also Gesellschaften wie vielleicht die
russische Gesellschaft in oder die
Gesellschaft in Saudi-Arabien wo wir
davon ausgehen können dass fairn ist da
eine sehr sehr untergeordnete Rolle in
dieser Gesellschaft spielt sind
wahrscheinlich so weit wir das Wissen
keine neidgesellschaften
hier liberaler demokratischer je mehr
Mittelschicht da ist umso größer ist der
Neid weil die Erwartung ist dass hier
jeder zu seinem kommt und wenn man das
Gefühl hat ich bin aber nicht zu meinem
gekommen aber mein Nachbar ist das und
das ist eigentlich unverschämt und wieso
kriegt er eigentlich dafür so viel Geld
und so weiter dann wächst der Neid und
das Interessante ist dass dieses Gefühl
diese angeborene Sinn für Unfairness die
einem widerfährt dass wir den aus dem
Tierreich haben es gab Anfang der 2000er
Jahre diese bahnbrechenden Experimente
die Franz der Wahl an der Emery
University in Atlanta gemacht hat mit
kapuzinerhafen die sind sehr berühmt die
kann man auch bei Youtube angucken also
dass man gesprochen
ja also das Prinzip ist es kam immer
zwei Kapuziner Affen wurden gefüttert
und zwar wahlweise mit Gurken und mit
Weintrauben die wurden reingeworfen in
den Käfig aber nur wenn die Affen
Spielmarken die auch rein geworfen
wurden die Chance raus erreicht haben
das heißt also Spielmarken kamen in den
Käfig ja der kapuzineraffe hebt mir auf
gibt die raus und dann kriegt eine Gurke
oder eine Weintraube und aus der Sicht
von Kapuzineraffen schmecken Gurken so
lala und Weintrauben schmecken großartig
jetzt wussten die Affen natürlich wenn
Sie die Jetons rausreichten
sie eine Gurke na ja kann man essen ja
und kriegt eine Weintraube super so
nachdem wir das schön eingespielt hatten
und alle gut konnten haben sie die Affen
getrennt in zwei zwei Käfige aber die
konnten einander sehen
und wenn der Affe in dem ersten Käfig
seine Spielmarken rausreichte bekamer
Gurken und wenn der Affe in den zweiten
Käfig seine Spielmarken rausreichte
kriegt er Weintrauben
und was passiert hier ja der Affe in dem
ersten Käfig stellte innerhalb kürzester
Zeit die Arbeit ein
natürlich war er bereit gewesen für
gurkenlohn zu arbeiten aber doch nur
unter der Voraussetzung dass das nicht
jemand genau gleiche Tätigkeit
Weintrauben kriegt
angeborener Sinn für Unfairness die
einem wieder fährt aber was anderes ist
wäre ein Sinn für Fairness den haben
Kapuzineraffen nicht und ich habe meinen
Vorträgen immer gesagt sind verfeines
wäre gewesen wenn der Affe in dem ersten
Käfig die Hälfte der Weintrauben dir
sogar umsonst gekriegt hat an den Affen
in dem zweiten Käfig abgegeben hätte da
hat mal jemand aus dem Publikum
geschrieben das wäre Sozialismus aber
das aber das stimmt nicht Sozialismus
ist wenn es erst gar keine Weintrauben
geht richtig richtig sondern nur Gurken
genau ja es ist Sozialismus ist die
Abwesenheit von Bananen ja in dieser
Logik sozusagen dieser Logik aber das
interessante an der Sache ist also
dieses Gefühl in einem drin ja hier
werde ich benachteiligt ja hier geht's
gegen meine Interessen wieso kriegt der
was ich nicht kriege
das findet man bei Kindergartenkindern
usw in allen Gesellschaften das man nie
aus dem Menschen herausbekommen die
Kunst besteht darin dieses Gefühl in
fruchtbare Gewässer umzumünzen und aus
einem angeborenen Sinn für unfairn ist
die ein widerfährt sowas wie ein Sinn
für Fairness zu werden genau und das ist
möglich aber nur mit viel erzieherischer
Begleitung ja ich meine du haben wir
auch schon mal angetickt ne wenn du
überlegst du kriegst die Gehaltserhöhung
und du kriegst vom Chef gesagt was auf
500 € mehr für dich jeden Monat Du
freust Dich genauso lange darüber bist
du erfährst dass der der neben dir sitzt
tausend Euro mehr kriegt jeden Monat
dann ist vorbei ja der guten Laune das
ist genau das
ist die einem wieder fährt genau und du
siehst es ja auch ist ja interessant und
unser ganze Steuersystem z.B ist der
letzten Endes auch so auch aufgebaut ne
also die diese berühmte kalte
Progression die sozusagen dafür sorgt
dass sie je mehr du verdienst desto mehr
geht dann auch weg
ist ja im Grunde an der Antwort
sozusagen auf einen möglichen nicht Neid
ist das falsche Wort Fairness ein
Fairness Gedanke der sozusagen davon
beeinträchtigt ist wenn das alles immer
schon gleich geht ja und das Gefühl die
da oben werden immer reicher und die da
unten haben irgendwie egal wie sie sich
anstrengen kommen einfach nicht weiter
genau
der Versuch eines Kompromiss ist aus
Kapitalismus Radikale im Kapitalismus
ja und äh außer er muss Steuern zahlen
damit der Staat militärinfrastruktur
Polizei und Ordnung und so weiter
aufrecht erhält aber mehr sollte er
nicht zahlen müssen und Sozialismus ja
wo ist darum geht möglichst auf eine
Gesellschaft hinzuarbeiten die den
optimalen sozialen Ausgleich schaffen
und irgendwas in der Mitte dazwischen
ist Steuersystem
genauierbar ist das heißt diejenigen die
ganz wenig haben finden dass sie reichen
viel zu wenig Steuern zahlen und die
reichen dass sie viel zu viel sein
richtig und das ist in allen
Gesellschaft und es gibt ja für beides
ja dem Beleg also den vermeintlichen
Beleg ja du kannst ja als als jemand der
Arm ist kannst du ja argumentieren und
sagen was auf die die werden besteuert
auf eine Art und Weise das steht in
keinem Verhältnis zu dem Vermögen dass
sie besitzen das geht so eigentlich
nicht kann doch nicht sein dass jemand
in der Lage ist einfach Milliarden zu
horten und dann wird das irgendwie nicht
richtig besteuert weil es ja dann um
Vermögen geht und nicht um Einkommen ja
Einkommensteuer ist in Deutsch Arbeit
ist teuer Einkommen wird unglaublich
hoch besteuert werden Vermögen
vergleichsweise niedrig besteuert wird
so und die Reichen sagen natürlich das
kann ja wohl nicht sein also wir die die
obersten zehn Prozent sind aber
zuständig für mindestens 50 60 70% des
Steueraufkommens also wo sind wo ist da
der Vorwurf wo ist das Problem wir
leisten unverhältnismäßig viel nee aber
das Gefühl dass in einer richtigen
Balance halten zu müssen ist ja offenbar
auch in der Politik ganz mal nicht fest
deswegen macht man das ja auch so genau
wieder in der Maßstab ist letztlich es
gibt ja keinen Maßstab dafür ne also
objektiven gibt es nicht also es gibt
keinen von Gott gewollten Steuersatz wo
man sagen will das ist jetzt genau
richtig ja und es wird auch nie eingeben
der die Zustimmung aller bekommt sondern
mal guckt im Zweifelsfall was machen die
Nachbarländer genau und dann guckt man
was unterscheidet uns von denen und was
können wir machen was können wir nicht
machen und sich das mit Regierung mal so
ein bisschen Linie eine Richtung ein
bisschen in die andere Richtung
auffälligerweise ist es so dass
normalerweise die Sozialdemokraten die
Steuern senken und die Konservativen sie
anheben wenn sie regieren ist auch
interessant wenn der höchste Steuersatz
der je gezahlt wurde in Deutschland
wurde in Zeiten von Helmut Kohl gezeigt
das berühmten Arbeit
gemacht ja das hängt einfach damit
zusammen dass die Parteien wenn sie
lange einer Macht bleiben wollen beim
politischen gegnerischen
ist richtig ja genau und die die die
Experimente dazu weil du gerade von von
Affen sprichst sind echt interessant ne
also Neid ist sozusagen ja bei uns zu
negativ konnotiert aber ich glaube es an
ein
wichtiges Gefühl sozusagen um so eine
Gesellschaft am Laufen zu halten ja also
Experimente mit Affen wo du siehst die
leben ja in klaren Hierarchien und dann
leben sie auch gut weil sie
weiß klare Regeln gibt klare Leitplanken
und trotzdem müssen sie so ein bisschen
darauf achten dass die Gruppe
anpassungsfähig bleibt ne und dann ist
es gut wenn die Affen untereinander so
ein Gewissen Leid entwickeln und dann
stellt sozusagen am Rang niedriger Affe
immer mal wieder sozusagen den Rang des
Rang höchsten Affen in Frage weil er
neidisch ist ja und daraus entsteht
sozusagen eine gewisse Beweglichkeit
eine gewisse andere allerdings
Hierarchien Leben z.B genau wir haben ja
über die Bonobos schon gesprochen nee
bei Null sein Konfliktlösung über also
jemand der sexuell völlig befriedigt ist
der ist danach nicht neidisch ja und in
dem Moment wo der Neid oder irgendwas
anderes wieder aufkommt oder so dann
kriegt er das nicht so Vergnügen und bei
Gibbons die in lebenslangen tatsächlich
Träume unheimlich selten im Tierreich
treuen zweier Beziehungen leben und mit
anderen Gibbons ansonsten noch nichts zu
tun haben ja sondern sich einfach nur
lieben zu zweit ihr ganzes Leben
miteinander zu verbringen und wenn der
Partner stirbt zum Beispiel ein bis zwei
Jahre solo bleiben vor Trauer Wahnsinn
ne ja ist übrigens interessant unsere
letzten Sendung hat mal jemand das
kommentiert und hat gesagt ich würde
irgendwie wer kein Biologe ich würde mal
das Tierreich quasi anthropomorphisieren
ne wenn ich sage die Liebe geworden ja
oder die Kraken ja die sind so sensibel
und die die die die die vergnügen sich
unheimlich war ein Liebesspiel ich
möchte mal ganz klar dazu sagen Biologen
neigen dazu natürlich nicht alle gibt
auch gute Biologen aber viele Biologen
neigen dazu ihre Experimente und das was
sie an Tieren erforschen maximal zu
versachlichen ja also sagen bloß nicht
über Gefühle reden oder irgendwo Gefühle
rein projizieren und ich halte das
deswegen für falsch weil wenn ein
Verhaltensforscher von einem anderen
Stern der jetzt eher sehr viel
intelligenter wäre als der Mensch oder
so Albert Einstein einen Tag lang oder
eine Woche lang beobachtet hätte was
macht er so am Tag man hätte vor allen
Dingen festgestellt der zieht sich
morgens an und der ist und abends sieht
er sich wieder aus und so weiter sitzt
irgendwie ein bisschen am Schreibtisch
und geht so zur Uni da wäre etwas so als
sachliches dabei rausgekommen dass alles
das was das Innere von Albert Einstein
ausmacht und als ist das was seine
wirklichen Leistungen was ihn bewegt
anbelangt nicht erfasst und das ist der
gleiche Blick den Biologen in dem
Versuch der Verwissenschaftlichung auf
andere Tiere werfen
das interessanter Gedanke
ich hatte Thema Gier ja jetzt haben wir
über Neid gesprochen Neid und gear das
ist ja alles ganz nah beieinander welche
Note gibst du dir in Sachen dir ja also
wenn jetzt mit dir nur materiellegier
genannt ist dann habe ich nicht so viel
davon das liegt wahrscheinlich an meiner
extrem prägenden Erziehung ne Status
Symbole waren bei uns zu Hause verpönt
na da hätte ich also nur wenn ich nur
mistkredit geraten mit großen Auto und
für ein freier sowieso gar kein Auto
oder wenn ich jetzt meinte das hast du
gar kein Auto ich habe in meinem Leben
zwei Tage ein Auto gesessen mit dem
nicht gefahren der nette Vorbesitzer ein
sehr guter Freund von mir hat er sich
noch mal ausgeliehen er stellte fest
dass die Bremse nicht richtig
funktioniert und hat damit einen Unfall
produziert den hat er gut überlebt das
war nicht schlimm für ihn ich hätte den
wahrscheinlich als schlechte Autofahrer
nicht überlebt und ich dachte also mehr
Zeichen ja mehr mehr götterwinkel kann
eigentlich gar nicht sein
ich bin zwar in meinem Leben dann
häufiger Auto gefahren in Afrika z.B wo
ist kein Verkehr gibt
aber auch keine richtigen Straßen genau
gefährlich und so weiter aber ich war
hier eigentlich kein Auto und ich
besitze auch keins
und also den materielle gear hält sich
in Grenzen aber wenn dazu gieren
natürlich auch noch Neugier oder sowas
gehört ja oder überhaupt das sozusagen
massive Streben nach irgendwas dann habe
ich da ordentlich was von abgekriegt
aber also eine drei als mischsensor ja
genau du kennst ja diesen berühmten Satz
von Gandhi ne die Welt hat genug für
jedermanns Bedürfnisse aber nicht für
jedermanns Gier
ist natürlich richtig finde ich so dass
das so gut beschrieben und trotzdem will
ich auch da sagen gehe ist ja etwas was
uns unvorstellbar treibt das treibt das
treibt die Welt unsere Welt unsere
marktwirtschaftliche Welt auf eine
unglaubliche Art und Weise sehr
Kapitalismus genauso oft hier angewiesen
wie oft Neid ja Michael ja seine sein
größter Feind ist die Zufriedenheit
richtig genau eine Gesellschaft aus
lauter materiell gesättigten zufriedenen
Menschen kommt in den Stillstand und
übernimmt sofort die nächste totsünde
für träge ja es ist richtig vorbei also
ja wie soll man wie soll man der
Trägheit etwas entgegensetzen wenn man
nicht von irgendeiner gear besehen wird
also hier widersprechen sich die beiden
tot sind das stimmt das stimmt ich habe
gerade neulich mit mit mit meinem Sohn
darüber gesprochen die die jüngere
Generation wirklich viele von denen
bedeuten Autos z.B nichts mehr ja das
ist die Gier nach dem Auto die die die
ist in ländlichen Bereichen ja da ist
aber würde ich es nicht hier nennen
sondern das ist das Auto eine schlicht
in Notwendigkeit du brauchst das Auto um
von A nach B zu kommen und wenn auch die
Zahlen die dazu mal anguckst dann siehst
du wie weltfremd vieles ist was da
politisch teilweise so als postuliert
und gefordert wird und dann sagt alle
müssen auf öffentlichen Nahverkehr
umsteigen er gucke ich mal um im
ländlichen Raum 80% des das Verkehrs
läuft über Autos weil das andere
schlicht und ergreifend nicht da ist ja
und da ist auch so eine so ein so ein
Frustpotenzial ne wenn dann sozusagen
Generation aber viele jüngeren
Generationen auf dem Lande tendenziell
auch also da wo wo man nicht mit Uhr
fährt und kein Carsharing macht und ich
mit E-Rollern von A nach B kommt und so
weiter also in dieser Welt spielt das
Auto noch eine Rolle und wird es sicher
auch noch recht machen und die Leute
haben auch die Nase voll davon dass
ihnen sozusagen
irgendwelche gutverdienenden Akademiker
aus der Stadt erzählen jetzt lass das
mal mit dem Auto weil es verpestet nur
die Umwelt und die sagen du
entschuldigung ich brauche aber mein
Auto und dann erklärst du ihn auch noch
jetzt musst Du eh fahren weil sowieso
und und morgens Weltuntergang und Umwelt
Zerstörung alles richtig aber auf der
anderen Seite ich kann mir das E-Auto
schlicht und ergreifend nicht leisten ja
weil E-Autos immer noch deutlich mehr
kosten als Verbrenner also da ist glaube
ich viel viel Potenzial für Frust aber
ich habe so gedacht die die diese
jüngere Generation ja die die die machen
vielleicht den Führerschein vielleicht
auch nicht aber Autos bedeutet denen
nichts und ich finde es interessant wie
sich da Wertvorstellungen verändert
haben
eher von biodeutschen das würde ich
schon sagen also wenn ich mir angucke
wenn statuskarossen durch Düsseldorf
fahren dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass jemand Migrationshintergrund drin
sitzt relativ hoch also es gibt diese
Marke mit dem Stern die ist beliebt bei
deutschen Rentnern und bei jüngeren
Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund ich
habe da auch mal mit dem Vertreter der
Automobilindustrie gesprochen und der
hat das auch bestätigt also das ist
nicht nur
anekdotische Evidenz ja sondern das ist
tatsächlich so ja
zwei drei andere Marken kann und so
ich kann dir das erklären
letztendlich sprichst du über mich die
die die die Sache mit dem
Migrationshintergrund ich glaube
Alter Migrationshintergrund
[Gelächter]
lucos talking sage ich nur
herrlich ich finde nur der der Punkt ist
worüber redest du ich ich würde es
loslösen ich persönlich vom
Migrationshintergrund für mich hat das
mit Migrationshintergrund nichts zu tun
das geht um was ganz anderes es geht
darum du redest über Menschen die
erstmal von ganz unten anfangen mussten
die erstmal sozusagen denn das fällt mal
von hinten auf Rollen musste in dem
Leben und die dieses Gefühl haben ich
habe eine Rechnung offen mit dem Leben
ja da da da gibt's etwas das möchte ich
auch da möchte ich auch hin das hat mich
Migrationshintergrund nichts zu tun also
wenn ich sage
migrationshintergrundierung genau
sondern dann weiß ich auch dass das mit
dem du damit zu tun hat in welchem
sozialen Milieus ist dass du weißt
eine riesen Rolle wenn du dir einen
Dreizack kaufst ja also
also in dem Moment wurde der das machst
dann ist das natürlich ein wahnsinniges
Gefühl wenn eine ganze Clique dich dafür
bedelt
und es gibt einfach vielleicht wenn dein
Sohn das tun würde oder wie auch immer
würde er von seiner Clique schräg
angeguckt das spielt ja eine große Rolle
diesmal egal ne darum geht's nicht nein
doch darum geht's ich glaube es geht
einfach darum dass die Status Symbole
von Hipster einfach andere Status
Symbole sind als auf den Aufsteigern
und so weiter wieso nicht alles Hipster
ja daneben sowas eine richtige Ausdruck
alter junge Junge zu welcher
Statusgruppe gehört denn dein Sohn wie
nennt wie nennt man Anfang 20-Jährige
die nicht primär an materiellen Status
Gütern interessiert sind wie nennt man
die denn junge Leute
voll befriedigende Antwort
der noch mal der andere aber es ist
interessant gibt es kein Auto Richard
das du jemals besitzen wolltest kein
Auto von dem du sagst boah das ist das
Ding zwei verschiedene Dinge also es
gibt Autos wo ich sagen würde die finde
ich richtig schön sagt das heißt aber in
meinem Fall ausnahmsweise nicht dass ich
sie besitzen will ja ich finde ja ich
habe das auch schon mal gesagt ich finde
dass der Auto aus den letzten 30 Jahren
unglaublich hässlich geworden sind seit
den 80ern geht's ja mit Autos bergab ne
aus meinem Opa Geschmack heraus
wir werden ja oft mit Waldorf von
Stadtlauf verglichen ja und ich werde
das jetzt hier bestätigen und sagen
früher Autos noch schön ja also ich ich
finde so ein so ein Jaguar E-Type ist
ein unglaublich schönes Auto z.B fuhr
halt nie
völlig egal ob der fuhr oder nicht wo du
hast gefragt ob ich die schön finde
also wenn es um Schönheit geht ist die
Funktionalität ja nicht mehr ganz so
wichtig als jemand der nicht fährt weißt
du ich ich bin nicht der Mensch der so
das Gas wird also langsam runter drückt
und dann heult das Auto wie so ein
Jaguar auf und dann fühlt man sich
selbst wie so ein Jaguar und so du
kennst das ja aber das nicht ich war so
nicht Auto ich fahre so nicht Auto
wirklich ich fahre so nicht out aber ich
verstehe zum Beispiel und ich
respektiere das auch wenn wenn jemand
sagt mein Traum dieser neuen Elfer
diesen Porsche den will ich unbedingt
haben du bist doch gut es ist doch gut
wenn es in dieser Gesellschaft Menschen
gibt die bereit sind 150 200 000 € für
ein Auto auszugeben denkst du mal an all
die die da hinzuffenhausen und anderswo
am Band stehen und die ihr ihr ihre
ganze Existenz ja mit diesem Auto
verbunden haben die darauf angewiesen
sind dass Leute bereits sind auf der
anderen Seite am oberen Ende sozusagen
das zu bezahlen ist doch ich glaube
das in überhaupt Porsche-Fahrer ist
sozusagen also wenn du sagst was ist ein
Neid Symbol dann ist es genau der
Porsche-Fahrer also wenn Christian sagt
hätte alles genau funktioniert
breiten Reichweite das gleiche gilt ja
auch für die couren und so weiter es
gibt ja Leute die sammeln sündhaft
teures Porzellan das kostet vielleicht
genauso eine mingoase oder so die
genauso viel kostet wie so ein Porsche
die löst kein Neid aus ja weil es kein
wichtiges status symbol in unserer
Gesellschaft ist und Porsche wird halt
zu den letzten Marken bei denen das noch
so ist
hier ist gut leben hier ist die und
Dreizack und so
hier ist gut die ist richtig gier ist
gesund du hast Wall Street gesehen da
haben wir alle damals gehabt Michael
Douglas also Gordon Gecko ja und das war
ist so die die der der sagen alles auf
den Punkt gebracht nee also ich hatte
sowieso damals gesehen und dachte dieser
Film ist der Inbegriff dessen was schief
läuft in der Welt und ich konnte Michael
Douglas dann auch in keiner anderen
Rolle mehr sehen über mindestens zehn
Jahre hinweg oder für das Arschloch zu
halten dass er in diesem Spiel in diesem
Film spielt genau das aber sicherlich
ist
bin dann lange lange identifiziert
bei Leonardo DiCaprio
genial gehen ja besser geht's nicht
verkörpert ja
also nichts gespielt es stimmt mit
Sicherheit nicht es gigantische
schauspielerische Leistung großartig
aber ich meine wie der ein in den Bann
zieht und gleichzeitig ultra auf den
Sack geht in dem Film ist sehr
beeindruckend ich glaube charismatische
gespielt als ich diese halbwegs waren
Begebenheit mal zugetragen ja ich finde
die Rolle übrigens von Matthew mcconnery
in dem Film völlig unterschätzt grandios
so grandios wie er dem dem dem Jungen
die Caprio erklärt wie das da
funktioniert an der Börse und so weiter
ja die sind absolut schlecht
genau
was soll man Gier also gier ist etwas
ich sag mal ohne Gier funktioniert der
ganze Laden nicht ne ja brauchen wir
also eine Bedarf wenn Mann
ohne dass wir jetzt die Michael Douglas
Zitate übernehmen und sagen dir ist
deswegen gut nee nee nee
sagen hier ist bis zu einem gewissen
gerade nützlich
aber auf der anderen Seite wissen wir ja
auch dass der ganze Laden dabei ist
ökologisch gegen die Wand zu fahren und
deswegen ist mir natürlich mindestens im
gleichen Ausmaß auch schädlich ja ich
wollte nur sagen also ich will es gar
nicht werden es ist nur sozusagen
Beschreibung des Mechanismus also unsere
Welt funktioniert nicht wenn wir nicht
in der Lage sind die Gier bei den Leuten
zu wecken es geht sogar bis hin zu dem
Punkt an dem man sich doch fragen muss
hat es möglicherweise was mit dir zu tun
dass wir gerade z.B die Inflation sehen
die so vielen Leuten so zu schaffen
macht ist es die Gier von Unternehmen
die unter die Gier von Konzernen die
dafür sorgt dass wir dass wir gerade
eine Inflation haben von der man so
woher kommt die jetzt eigentlich so
genau ne das würde ich nicht sagen weil
das ist nicht die Gier sondern das ist
einfach aus Sicht dieser Unternehmen und
großen Aktiengesellschaften und so
weiter eine schlichte Notwendigkeit
also wenn eine Aktiengesellschaft nicht
gierig in dem Sinne ist ja dass sie dass
sie ihren Umsatz steigern will oder dass
sie nicht absteigen will oder neue
Märkte erschließen will und
rationalisieren will und so weiter dann
ist sie weg deswegen der Begriff Gier
klingt ja so wie eine
Charaktereigenschaft genau und das macht
die Sache schwierig ne der im
Kapitalismus wenn man den jetzt so
neutral beschreibt da ist die dir keine
Charaktereigenschaft da ist einfach
dieses unersättliche Streben nach Meer
ein System immanenter Mechanismus ohne
denen das ganze nicht funktioniert und
zwar ganz neutral zu beschreiben richtig
nicht wertend nee das meine ich ja
milken ne ganz ganz berühmter
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler den sich ja
viele auch immer beziehen
Nobelpreisträger klassischer neoliberale
geeignet das Feindbild gerade sagen also
der Gordon Gecko sozusagen der der
richtige ja der der Mann
das lästigste Übel der Welt wirklich und
und nach dem Motto gibt der Wirtschaft
den möglichst freien Lauf und wird alles
gut und das hat er ja dann mit äußerster
Brutalität in Chile praktiziert und das
Land dann noch weiter in den Ruinen
getrieben erklär kurz ja also Milton
Friedman waren nachdem pinochee diesen
blutigen Putsch gemacht hatte 73 in
Chile und die einzige jemals frei
gewählte kommunistische Regierung der
Welt gestürzt hatte hat dann das
Programm der Chicago Boys also von
Hilton Friedman der da auch häufiger war
ja und dem häufig die Hand geschüttelt
hat und den Arm um die Schulter gelegt
versucht zu verwirklichen probieren wir
doch mal in einem südamerikanischen
Staat aus wie ist das wenn wir den
ganzen Sozialstaat so gut wie abschaffen
und nur den Markt regieren lassen und
das hat viele über Jahrzehnte hinweg
unendlich geschadet und hat vor allen
Dingen dazu geführt dass das ganze Tafel
Silber dieses rohstoffreichen Landes vor
allem Kupfer alles in die Hände
ausländischer Firmen gefallen ist und
hat das Land ausgeblutet bis zum geht
nicht mehr denke ich immer wieder was
Ideologie anrichten kann und vorstellbar
es gibt nicht nur völlig kaputte
kommunistische Ideologie es gibt auch
völligen kaputte kapitalistische richtig
gibt diesen berühmten Satz von Friedman
ne sagen Sie mir mal gibt's überhaupt
eine Gesellschaft die nicht aufgehbar
sind glauben Sie das Russland nicht von
dir angetrieben wird glauben sie dass
China nicht von dir angetrieben wird und
was ist Dir natürlich ist keiner von uns
gierig nur der andere ist immer gierig
aber die Welt lebt von Individuen die
ihre eigene Interessen verfolgen das
natürlich schon was dran absolut und
alles worüber wir diskutieren müssen
sind was sind wohlverstandene eigene
Interessen genau also wenn ich jetzt nur
rücksichtslos an meinem eigenen
persönlichen Vorteil interessiert bin
kann das sein dass ich irgendwann in
einem Land lebe in dem ich nicht mehr
leben will
also die die richtige Ballons zwischen
zu seinem kommen nach Erfolgsstreben und
auf der einen Seite und sozialen
Ausgleich auf der anderen Seite macht
erfolgreiche Gesellschaften aus und wohl
verstanden das eigene eigene Interesse
denkt an beides
ohne die Gier der Konsumenten werden
keine Autos gekauft keine
Flachbildschirme keine iPhones keine
Aquarien und wenn keiner kauft sinken
die Steuereinnahmen und der Sozialstaat
geht baden ohne die Gier der anderen
kein Herz vier für die einen wie soll
den Bankern heute Unrecht sein was sonst
immer recht war wer hat das geschrieben
ja ich habe mal ich habe mal was über
über dir geschrieben fürs ZEITmagazin
kann sein dass es dafür ist oder für so
ein Kalendertage gemacht hat genau aber
das sind interessanter Gedanke also ohne
die Gier der einen geht der Sozialstaat
für die anderen Baden ne ja das ist so
wie das System funktioniert ist das
genauso ich habe das geschrieben in Zeit
in dieser Zeit der Finanzmarktkrise wo
ist darum ging das einige war immer die
Rede von den schwarzen Schafen und von
der Bosheit der Gier genau und ich habe
zwei riesige Kritik einer
Finanzwirtschaft fand aber diese
psychologische unterbrechen auf den
giermechanismus viel zu primitiv
angesichts der Komplexität der Probleme
und es nützt überhaupt nichts individual
psychologisch zu sagen ja hier dieser
der Gorilla da der der niemand Boss nee
ist besonders böse und die und die
Banker von der und der Bank und so
weiter die Waren zu gierig
das ist zwar eine völlig unterkomplexe
Sichtweise darauf dass hier ein System
nicht vernünftig reguliert ist und wo
man auf die Gier des Einzelnen gegangen
ist um sich keine Sorgen zu machen und
nicht allzu viele Gedanken zu machen um
den Mechanismus des Ganzen und dann habe
ich in diesem Kontext auch die gear
verteidigt interessant Richard weißt du
was ich schlage folgendes vor wir machen
an dieser Stelle einen Punkt aber es ist
so viel liegen geblieben Trägheit
Hochmut also ja
und uns auch noch fünf Minuten zu
vergessen das ist richtig ja ich ich
schulde dir noch was beim Thema Gier ja
ja würde ich immer sagen so wie wir hier
auch gerade beschrieben haben ja
sozusagen wenn als etwas was ja letzten
Endes auch den den Wunsch beschreibt
sozusagen auch was vom Kuchen abhaben zu
wollen und sich dafür auch echt
anzustrengen
da würde ich sagen also da bin ich bei
einer vier bin ich da dabei du bist ja
ein Fuchs ne du gibst dir jetzt hier wo
es ungefährlich ist die schlechten
Zensuren um dir nachher noch lauter
Einsen geben zu können
dass ich dir noch was schulde und falls
dir nicht aufgefallen ist habe ich
gedacht okay dann liefer ich das
freiwillig okay gut dann unterhalten wir
uns beim nächsten Mal mal über die
anderen okay so so nebenbei ja wenn die
Gier vorbei ist dann setzt als nächstes
als Konsequenz daraus die Trägheit ein
und das ist ein total interessanter
Punkt
Deutschen und die noch faulere Jugend
von heute ja ob das wirklich so ist wir
werden es besprechen danke sehr ja ja
genau
[Musik]
im Auftrag des ZDF